we know that we must to lay claim to any
respectability or competence keep up
with the news
that's why we've ringed the earth with
satellites crisscross state with fiber
optic cables and created networks of
news bureaus that inform us with urgency
of pretty much any event to have
unfolded anywhere on the planet in the
last few moments we are furthermore
equipped with tiny devices that we keep
very close to ham so as to monitor all
unfolding stories in close to real-time
we've been granted a ringside seat on
the second-by-second flow of history as
a result we see a lot more and at the
same time strangely we see a lot less
the constant presence of news from
without hampers our ability to pick up
on an equally important though far less
prestigious source of news from within
we are not by nature well-equipped to
see inside ourselves consciousness Bob's
like a small boat on a sea of disavowed
emotions a lot of feelings and ideas
require a high degree of courage to
confront they threaten to make us
uncomfortably anxious excited or sad
will we to learn more about them so we
use the news without to silence of the
news from within we have the most
prestigious excuse ever invented not to
spend too much time roaming freely
inside our own minds it's not that the
news from without is unimportant to
someone indeed it will be the most
important thing in certain people's
lives our continent away or in a company
in the capital or somewhere in the upper
reaches of government its
just that this news is almost certainly
wholly disconnected from our real
priority over the coming years which is
to make the most of our life and our
talents in the time that remains to us
it's touching that we should give so
much of our curiosity over to strangers
but it's poignant that we are forced
eventually to pay such a high price for
this constant dispersal of energy we
dismiss fragile tentative thoughts about
what we should do next who we should
call what we really need to do thoughts
upon which an adequate future for us
depends for the sake of the more obvious
drama of the moment but the drama won't
save us it cares not a jot about our
development or our real responsibilities
it feels counterintuitive to think that
there might be certain things much more
important than the news but there is our
own lives which we have troublingly been
granted such prestigious reasons and
means to avoid confronting
we can educate ourselves in the art of
being calm not through specialties or
slow breathing but through thinking this
book guides us through that process